one of the most exciting reveals at San
Diego Comic Cons Hall age panel was the
reveal of Thor for Thor love and thunder
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
a lot of people including myself are
really really excited to see Thor 11
Thunder especially since they revealed
to us at San Diego comic-con Jane Foster
is going to return and she is going to
be playing a female version of Thor and
this is a storyline that is straight
from the comics and is one of my
favorites and if things weren't already
exciting enough with the announcement of
Thor at love and thunder we are getting
reports now that the villains for Thor
love and thunder have been revealed so
I'll break down both of these villains
in this video and talk about how one of
them ties directly to Galactus also if
you'd like a chance to win a ps4 or an
Xbox one be sure to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your favorite superhero or
villain so it is actually being reported
that there are two villains for Thor
love and thunder the first one is one of
Thor's greatest enemies enchantress
Enchantress's parentage is unknown but
she was born in Asgard and she began to
learn magic as an apprentice of the
queen of the Nords but was eventually
banished she continued to learn magic by
seducing others who knew magic very well
and learning their secrets since Jane
Foster Thor is going to be in Thor love
and thunder it makes sense that
enchantress would be one of the villains
because Enchantress's first appearance
in the comics is her being sent by
Thor's father Odin to eliminate Thor's
human love interest who of course we
know is Jane Foster now of course we
know that Odin has passed on and went to
Valhalla but still the connection is
there between Jane Foster and The
Enchantress it's also worth noting that
there are two Enchantress's one is the
original one and another is one that
Loki creates Loki created and modeled
her after the original enchantress and
created her as a tool for chaos which is
classic Loki so the Enchantress that we
will see in Thor love and thunder could
be created by Loki depending on the
route that they go
the second villain that is being
reported to appear in Thor love and
thunder is a relatively new villain only
making his first appearance in 2013 but
definitely a fan favorite and that is
gore the god butcher gore has a pretty
tragic backstory his mother his maid and
his children all die and do
this he thinks that gods cannot exist
and due to him not thinking that gods
exist his tribe banishes him however
Gore would eventually find out that the
gods do in fact exist but the fact that
they don't help those in need such as
his dying family makes him take a vow to
kill all of the gods Gore would go on to
possess the all-black necro sword which
is a sword of insane power he gets the
necro sword from no laughter witnessing
null in combat with a golden God
according to Galactus himself the sword
carved the first dawn from the stone of
the endless night and the sword was made
using the head of a killed celestial
does that sound a little bit familiar
we've seen the severed head of a
celestial and guardians of the galaxy
volume 1 and volume 2 and now serves as
the city nowhere so perhaps this is
where Gore will end up getting the all
black necro sword and Thor at love and
thunder the all black neck restored
grants the user the ability to fly by
giving the user wings it allows the
holder to create weapons and create an
army of berserkers constructed out of
darkness but the most important part
about the all-black necro sword is that
it can kill gods
so Gore of course gets the sword and
tries to kill Thor now Thor would
ultimately go on to defeat Gore and
would banish the sword into a black hole
however King Thor would eventually need
the sword to fight Galactus and since
Marvel and Disney now own the rights to
all of the Fox characters everybody is
starting to wonder when will Galactus
come into the MCU especially with the
introduction of the Fantastic Four Kevin
Feige announced that the Fantastic Four
are coming into the MCU most likely in
phase 5 and everybody is hoping that
with the arrival of the Fantastic Four
we will get the arrival of the Silver
Surfer and then of course Galactus
Galactus could be built up to be the
next big bad villain just like Thanos
was which is something that everybody
has been waiting for for an extremely
long time now and the fact that the
all-black necro sword is coming into the
MCU and it's something that Thor
literally uses at one point to fight
Galactus could be a sign that Galactus
could be coming down the road so let me
know what you think about these two new
villains enchantress and gore the
butcher being the two villains of Thor
love and thunder and also be sure to let
me know what you think about Galactus
possibly being the new big bad of the
MCU be sure to comment down below and
also comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this
and subscribe to my channel so you can
enter my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
wolf wolf